what's going on there citizens the
reject Nation we are going to watch
today a clip from the Super Mario
Brothers movie I think this was released
at the game awards John how are you I am
game tacular how are you doing good
thanks for joining me if you guys need
to catch my Jedi Survivor reaction that
is up here on the channel right now love
Fallen order so I was excited took that
trailer out alrighty let's see what's in
store leave a like leave the like button
leave it a like
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a little bit of that voice
yes
I've been there buddy
[Music]
get the sound design and the music it's
great
okay so these bricks are just floating
here
it's the only way to fly man
go go
classic oh got it here we are Palace
doors
Star platform
[Music]
Mushroom Kingdom still barely hearing
Chris Pratt's voice I know trying to get
a proper assessment of how I feel about
his voice such an up and down experience
but everything else was Grand and
beautiful that was like a no-brainer to
me I thought it looked it was just
harkening back to so much with the
gameplay there's so many just little
little tiny background Easter eggs are
out but I was really appreciative of
especially the sound design invigorating
that into your film Toad's voice sounds
excellent uh it's Keith Michael Keel
yeah they must have pitched him way up
yeah I mean it sounds to me it sounds
just absolutely excellent yeah and then
the classic tube pipe yes thank you yeah
man great sound design there it's a
great blend I think really because it
brings the world to life in a way that
is more immersive like a full-on movie
because you know like the game sound
designs are particular in the facts of
what they're accentuating for your
actual gameplay experience but yeah here
to hear it fleshed out with you know
additional just you know Street Sounds
and then the music really fun like and
upset as people have been about Mario's
design himself like watching him move
around I'm like this feels like you made
an open world Mario game basically a lot
of people are over it now yeah I feel
like maybe it's like the last hurdle is
the voice and even for me like you catch
a little bit of his voice when he's like
oh what is this this taupe thing you
know and you know he sounds like a New
Jersey guy he sounds again still sounds
like Rocket Raccoon to me but even
watching this I was like ah Rocket
Raccoon yeah he kind of sounds like
Rocket Raccoon to me you know Rockets
got that kind of you know he's got that
thing you know it's not great Rock but
you know he's got a similar accent at
least in what I'm gleaning here I'll
take it over everybody thinking that
Chris press just gonna talk like Chris
Pratt yeah well I think the ex the way
they've uh animated the Expressions too
feels human to me yeah yeah yeah yeah
the way Mario's designs are like I
really think they've brought that to
life in a great way like I enjoy the
references of like everything with like
the Super Mario World Super Mario 3D
like the map looks great eight the
Mushroom Kingdom and all that and I
think what I'm enjoying about what we're
getting with Mario thus far is the fact
that he seems like such a fish out of
water like you get so used to over the
years playing as Mario where some of
these reactions are a little bit more
slight like when he is jumping platforms
and stuff sometimes they do add in like
oh you know like a tiny bit but here he
looks truly terrified a lot of the time
and really scared and even when he's
going up the the the tube he's like
banging around and everything like that
and you get so used to over the years
playing confidently as Mario that I
think they're doing a really great job
at putting him in place as this
character who really needs to learn some
skills and really needs to learn how to
operate around the Mushroom Kingdom and
operate in this landscape as he's the
titular character going up against such
a big Baddie he has a big obstacle to
overcome it's not just going to be a
walk in the park for him I really like
that quality and you know as much as I'm
still working my brain around Chris
Pratt voice because it's the only voice
that I hear I don't know if it's just my
mental Association of I'm aware it's
Chris Pratt so I put a little bit more
emphasis on my my critical subconscious
ear on it you know or like when I still
have that even if I wasn't aware is
Chris Pratt doing it you know what I
mean yeah like is that interfering with
it I will say though that the few times
where the camera was on him and then he
was speaking I think it matches well
like it doesn't sound at all to me like
when I thought Mario would sound like
whatsoever I know you don't want to do
like uh
bad it'll be annoying after a while just
sound like that right sound like a noise
the entire time but I still think like
the way it matches like the the the
facial I mean the mouth vocal movement
with his lips and mouth and all that you
know what I mean sometimes I look like a
little bit awkward it matches well with
that at least yeah so my point with that
being is I imagine that it'll be it
simple enough experience to slip into
when you're watching even if you're like
it's not the Mario voice I really wanted
but for the movie it works and I think
that's ultimately what's going to matter
is like but for the movie it works yeah
absolutely because I mean this is a
Fresh coat of paint on everything and
and I think it's doing a nice job to
show us that like yeah this is very much
uh spawned from people who are you know
in love and know Mario well and I feel
like certain things will change and
certain things will stay familiar and
here like part of me wonders what their
motivation is because I'm like they
could quash all of this internet
mumbling if they just put out a full
scene of him talking but at the same
time I feel like they're also sort of
teasing us and and using the voice is
almost this kind of carrot at the end of
a stick but I I get the impression as of
now that yeah once you watch a few
minutes of just you know consecutive
movie with all that breathing room it'll
probably click into place you know it's
like hearing the 8-Bit things but in you
know this sort of lush polyphonic you
know realization especially in the
scoring and stuff like that and I don't
know like I feel like at least again the
hints that they're giving us give me it
hope they're not making me angrier and
I'm just taking that as a sign yeah
because I feel like it could easily take
things in that direction definitely but
yeah and I love what you said too about
his being a fish out of water because I
think there are a lot of times where you
have a property like this that is so big
and prolific for a lot of people where
you think oh do we really need that but
I think here it's a really nice choice
because yeah on a movie scale and
especially redefining from the 90s movie
I think it makes a lot of sense to jump
everybody in through this perspective
and then sure we can watch Mario go on
to be like a fully accomplished
Adventurer and all that stuff I don't
know yeah like his attitude Mario's kind
of cute like nobody really talks about
Mario that way but like he's endearing
here at least in the animation and I
kind of love that the animation itself
is able to lead that and you know is
able to endear me just based on you know
spending a few minutes in the world it
doesn't feel like we're just in another
Despicable Me alrighty well let me enjoy
the clip yeah Super Mario Brothers movie
clip what'd you guys think of it did you
like it leave your thoughts down below
be sure to subscribe leave a like last
one lessons
pandemic Jones PJ listen buddy I just
wanted to hop in here real quick and
tell you I hope you have a wonderful
Christmas let us know what you get for
Christmas this year I hope you're able
to gift people with your presence that
loving presence of yours and for 2023 I
just got a lot of spirit at this time it
stays in the video for 2023 I hope that
you are able to make boatloads of money
and you're able to convert those
boatloads of money into increasing your
pledge at patreon because let's face it
that's your real goal in life to just
contribute more to the real rejects
patreon page you're a good guy for doing
that and I respect the hell out of you
buddy
[Music]